Nó nghe thương định Mỹ, hà tại Alas Cà diễn xa Trung Quốc cạnh quan hệ 2 nước ở mức thấp nhất trong nhiều năm.
Ngà, quà phát biểu của thứ trưởng, hại sao sẽ gây viáp không?
Có đây là thời điểm quan trọng để khởi đặc của quả trình khăn gắn,
mở đường trợ tác ở một số lính vực, bao gồm khả nâng nối lại các truyền bây trở khách bị điên trị
từ năm 2018. Chá là thương nghĩ thương quan nhạy chẳng và bộ hại sao?
Những mạnh tính chức tham so của cục cập, nhằm tình nhiều lập trường của MUST Căva,
trước khi tiến tới bất kỳ bất đi chính nước nào,
phải tiếp cận này và nãy nhớ là tìm soát kỳ vòng,
giảng thiệu dụng gió tránh trị và tránh tạo un tượng về một chết tháng sớm trong nè.
Một kành xuân độc u khой nè, các cơm bộ pháp li của tè đồ với tổng thống của chiến,
và vẫn đề tài sản ngoại giao và là những nghiệm nắm,
một gà vì vải nước xem là phép từ chết lượng,
vừa mừng ra cơ hội đối thoại, với tiêm mạnh rối cơ khiến cục trẻ ngoại giao thiên phức tập.